one day my parents brought home a piano
it was the finest day I could I touched
it I knew there were things in it that
would thrill me I didn't know the
literature yet but so slowly that
happened and as I started playing little
pieces I I just said what what about
what about other things I didn't know if
they told then or Scarlatti or anything
else and so I said hmm maybe I'll start
reading and that was interesting because
that reading was the beginning of my
writing as well so I would get these
little Shermer editions of Chopin
Nocturne Zoar whatever or Wallis's I
remember I was given Wallace's first and
I read this incredible prose you know
the power of writing is your great power
because it is our our synthesis of
knowledge instantaneously everything we
know by instinct is put into words and
I'm listening to this right reading this
this man by the name of James Honaker
now this is the greatest of all American
critics not of just music but of these
seven arts if they say somehow all of
this mesh together I just loved loved
the wholeness of it the playing the
writing about it my old play and so
forth
certainly the most comprehensive
virtuoso that ever lived with a
repertoire from scarlotti to Santa
Barbara the American composer and when I
say that through radio I got to
interview him and I went to his home and
I put together six programs which were
really quite wonderfully the since you
sponsored by the grapefruit of Steinway
& Son and these these programs six one
hour's talks with him they were the
first time he had spoken on radio in New
York in 40 years and so I was very
pleased that you know he liked me a lot
I felt that and we did the programs and
they won the Peabody Award and I got
Yuma this award and I called him at home
you know this was maybe seven nine eight
ten months later and I said mr. Horowitz
you know our shows won a very important
award in America called the Peabody
Award little with you yes and I said
well would you like to come to the hotel
Pierre and receive the award with me
what time is it
I said it will be at 12 noon oh no no no
I don't end up in till 4:00 so you know
that was you didn't come to get his
award and he couldn't care less about
any award the only award I had saw many
awards from many countries you know from
Italy from the presidential medal you
name it and the only award that he cared
about which is written well in my book
about it is the bowtie award from
England that was the big award for him
and he this is XV award I love my
bowties you know how many I had you know
hundreds and they're all silk and and I
said well you know this is this is
terrific I mean that that bowtie award
looks good and and other nod we we we
didn't speak to each other for oh maybe
five six eight months after that and Tom
Frost his
at Sony and then Deutsche Grammophon I
said he said to Tom he said go David
Molyneux's is teaching piano literature
and actually I'll go and doesn't he come
and talk to me about Beethoven and
Chopin so Tom calls and says you know
why don't you go see him you know every
every night he has a different person a
week that dines with him and my day is
Tuesday and he would he would just love
to have you as part of this this small
little entourage and I said well I'll
certainly go see him you know I would
love to see him again I never afterwards
tried to get in his good graces once the
Mooney polity the programs were done I
wasn't going to bother him and I wasn't
going to say oh I'd like to know you
so I went to see him and then comes
three and a half years robbed of every
Wednesday I don't think I ever missed
one sometimes in the summer when other
people were gone I would do two or three
times a week and I must say that he was
the most wonderful man and after that I
did write a book about him called events
with Horowitz and then another book
which is being published in China very
soon called as well as here of course
called remembering heart words with 125
great virtue LC writing about him and
it's just it's an amazing cultural
history this book so I got to know him
and I want to tell you the great thing
about it because it was very not easy to
be with either them they were you know
who can we use the word neurotic I don't
know I'm neurotic but I can say that mr.
Horowitz and I always called them that
he said oh you know in the beginning
coffee Volodya
no Mike strong will never call you
Volodya I will only call you mr.
Horowitz or maestro and those are the
two words I called them and he said okay
and that was that was that he always
called me mr. Duvall and you always had
to you know be dressed up or they were
dressed up you didn't walk in as I'm
looking now there was one thing I didn't
wear at I always wore a scarf and that
he let that pass
[Music]
there is no one that I ever learned more
from I learned how that he touched the
piano how he made sonority how he used
the petal and from that I would say that
I learned how to teach many people how
to play the piano themselves or to
improve or to make a miracle of
something that was you know just
mediocre and in no time because as he
did he believes all things were learned
almost instantly and I could learn from
him because he wasn't teaching if he was
actually teaching me I would be like
[Music]